يعني حاليا نحن متواجدون في خيمه استقبال
الاسير المحرر الكريم يونس وكما ذكرت عن
عمر ناهد 66 عاما بعد ان قضي 40 عاما وقد
انهى محكوميه في السجون الاسرائيليه اليوم
كريم يعانق الحريه وفعليا نحن متواجدون
الان في بجانب منزل كريم حيث نشا وترعرع
قبل ان يتم اعتقاله وسجنه كما ترينا يعني
نحن الان متواجدون امام خيمه استقبال كريم
حيث توافد عدد كبير من ابناء الشعب
الفلسطيني بالرغم من يعني منعهم من سواء
الشعب الفلسطيني المتواجدين في الضفه
الغربيه وغزه الذين لم يستطيعوا المشاركه
وتهنئه كريم بالرغم ذلك هناك اعداد كبيره
ايضا هناك يعني وفود واعداد من الاسرى
المحررين الذين ايضا قدمه الى المنطقه
ويعني اعطوا ال- ال- او دعينا نقول انهم
القوا التحيه على كريم وهناؤوه بخروجه من
السجن فهذه هي الصوره حتى الان وبالرغم من
ذلك يعني بالرغم من التنكيس من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه ومحاوله تعاركت هذه الفرحه
الا ان هناك يعني اعداد كبيره كما ترين من
ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني ايضا قبل قليل كان
هناك همم يعني الاغاني الشعبيه ايضا في
المنطقه الاعلام الفلسطينيه ايضا يعني
هناك فرحه كبيره من ابناء الشعب سواء
الاشخاص الذين قدموا الى هنا او الاشخاص
الذين ايضا فرحوا لكريم في مناطقهم وفي
مدنهم سواء في الضفه الغربيه او في قطاع
غزه الذين لم يستطيعوا القدوم بالرغم من
قدوم اعداد كبيره ايضا من القدس ومن يافا
ومن عكا ومن كل المدن الفلسطينيه الى
المنطقه اللي انا ما امكانيه ان تلتقي به
وتتحدثين اليه
يعني نعم لقد التقينا قبل قليل فيه بالرغم
من وجود اعداد كبيره يرغبون التحدث الي
وايضا لقد يعني تحدثنا اليه هو يعني جدا
سعيد وايضا يرتعش من الفرحه داعينا نقول
بعد 40 عاما ولكن كما يقول هو يعني فرحته
لم تكتمل بسبب وفاه والدته قبل عده اشهر